all right well we are doing what we can
the first day of mass requirements now
reinstated for
employees in clark county it's now in
full swing victoria saha takes a look at
how it went
the staff here at mothership coffee just
took their masks off less than three
weeks ago
and now they have to put them back on
but they say
they're okay with it if we're doing the
best to protect ourselves
that is all we have control over romero
says even though the original covet 19
restrictions stopped on june 1st
her team continued to wear a mask a
little longer just to be
on the safe side which is why they don't
have an issue putting the masks back on
for my staff they're very mindful about
their own safety and the safety of
others so that's
the forefront of how they want to
approach the pandemic
on thursday when the mask mandate for
employees kicked in their first day of
business went on as usual
some customers even had masks on even
though they aren't required to
it's definitely difficult to encourage
customers without feeling like
we're in any way coercing over at all
for our country employees say they are
fully vaccinated but they don't have an
issue being masked up
it definitely gives me a sense of safety
so i really didn't mind
pontilla says she also noticed a lot of
her customers coming in wearing masks
but if covid cases don't improve she may
make it a requirement
victoria saha 8 news now with the new
mass mandate businesses are required to
put up signs that say that mass are
encouraged
this order will be reviewed again on
august 17th